how many years have you been working as
a sex worker so I'm 28 now I've started
when I was 20 so eight eight years yeah
and what have you learned about the idea
of the concept of marriage is it a
flawed concept yeah I feel like marriage
only um benefits if you're having
children
um but other than that I don't know I
kind of see it like a contract you know
because you have you have your clients
who are mostly married
almost all my clients are married you
and they sneak in when after work before
work before work sometimes after lunch
break so you know while the wives are
thinking my husband's heading out to
work he's actually coming a book a
provider right before work so and and
nobody knows about it nobody knows
probably not even their best male
friends yeah so it makes me look at you
know marriage very differently like I I
don't want to get married
it's
like what's the whole point in getting
married if the guy's going to step out
on me anyways you know there's
Temptation everywhere you got internet
social media like so so what's the
solution I mean I would love to be in a
relationship threeyear contract so you
have to renew every every three years or
something like
that renew what like a three-year
marriage and we're agreed to stick
around for three years and after three
years we either part ways or renew it
yeah I don't know just I heard somebody
suggest that yeah I mean I feel like um
a lot of
people they're in their ego when they're
in relationships it's like that's my
husband it's mine mine you don't own
that person you know what I'm saying so
at the end of the day that person's
going to do whatever they want to do
so I don't it's hard to keep that spark
alive yeah yeah definitely got to keep
that spark alive cuz I feel like we we
live in a world where people get bored
really easily you know there's that and
then there's also the hormonal changes
that happen to both men and women MH and
the pressures of life and finances and
and just yeah age and everything yeah
yeah life is tough life life ain't easy
so but you're still doing it I'm still
doing it yeah you regret it I don't
regret anything in my life I I feel like
everything in life is is a learning
lesson and I will forever be blessed for
the lessons that I've I've learned so I
love what I do you know yes I I help
people um I feel
like not only
like intimate wise but like mentally I
do help a lot of people out I've
interviewed a lot of girls that do what
you do MH and what I've seen is the ones
who look at it as is I'm providing a
service I'm like a therapist for these
guys I'm making them feel better and
they're not Hustlers they're not con
artists they're not thieves they're just
they like men and they're just trying to
help them and they understand that yeah
they're cheating around their wives and
that's not good but they're going to do
it anyway I guess they're going to do it
anyways yeah what what can I do I can't
really and and th those the women that
are that view it that way I think
there's actually hope of them having a
healthy relationship with a man outside
of this life or or or even existing you
know while you do it if a guy can handle
you doing that yeah it's hard for me cuz
I'm single and you know I haven't really
found anybody
that will settle down with me or or take
me serious probably because what I do
for work it is what it is maybe one day
I'll find somebody that's secure enough
to you know but there's some guys that
can live without that they probably they
probably like it yeah hey where they at
cuz I can't find them so yeah you talked
about this last time yeah it gets lonely
it definitely gets lonely cuz you know
in this industry you lose a lot of
friends you lose a lot of family I just
had a situation recently where I had to
kick out a family member cuz they were
pretty much living off of me they
weren't helping me out at all and they
didn't want to work and they just wanted
to just stay in my house all the time
and not do [__] so I'm like you got to
go I'm not going to be the only one here
pulling my weight doing what I do for
work and you're just you make money
you're not using drugs you're not I'm
clean you're living a pretty straight
life except for
this lifestyle that a lot of people like
to judge
yeah it's crazy that that a lot of
people have such a
Negative like mindset on the industry
you know it's such a Charged
polarizing topic yeah because everyone
hates it because you're cheating on
you're stealing on some you know
cheating on somebody's husband but let
let's clarify that I we're not stealing
nobody's husband that's number one you
know your husband goes on these sites
and looks for an ad and calls us you
know I wouldn't have known your husband
existed if he didn't reach out to me so
you know a lot of people need to stop
with that mindset of oh they're coming
I'm not trying to W you know I'm running
a business a honest living and I'm just
trying to live you know like most of the
uh providers in the industry been
through foster care you know have broken
families like we're just trying to live
so what I've learned after doing all
these interviews
is I don't know this as a fact but I
suspect if let's say prostitution was
somehow banned it just no longer existed
there would be a ton of mentally
unstable guys that are going to rape
people yes on the streets looking to do
something yeah and that can't be good
yeah I feel like if they were to at
least decriminalize it everywhere the
crime rate would go down tremendously
you
know I feel like it's it's deeper than
that I feel like the government wants to
keep the
minorities down here imagine if they
were to legalize it or decriminalize it
you know how many women make so much
money would be the bread winners and
then we would be up here mhm they don't
want
that Jim seon the divorce attorney I
interviewed recently said a woman's
attractiveness is the most valuable
commodity in our society yeah it is the
most valuable commodity yeah it's like
you got you guys
have have all the control at least pry
much at least for a time you know until
until you age out perhaps yeah
yeah but you're not allowed to really
Market that yeah unless you marry a rich
guy and divorce him that's true but the
beautiful thing about sex work I've
noticed is you can be old way older I've
there's a lot of women in the ranches
that are like 40 and they still make
money me personally I wouldn't be you
know working at the ranches at 40 I
think by 35 I'll retire um but I mean
that just goes to show anybody can make
money in the industry you don't have to
have your body done and I think it all
stems down to personality MH you know so
there's a woman for every yeah every guy
yeah I'm I'm 100% certain of that
everybody you know so many women I've
talk to said oh I need I need a boob job
or I need this I need that I need yeah
no you don't need you just need the
confidence because if you have the
confidence to know that you're you are
the [__] for somebody yeah it's all you
need yep
that's true so so many people are so
insecure they just think they're not
enough yeah we all have insecurities we
just got to you
know fight those uh those insecurities
yeah that's that's what pretty much
every video on my almost every video on
my channel is about yeah you working
Bros still no so I left um I was
supposed to go back in
June and I was like I'm not I'm good I
they did something funny to me um I'm
over it but just to shed light on how
funny these establish establishments
move um I had a
situation where um so this particular
house they do receipts every Saturday so
they call you into the office and they
pretty much go over how much money you
made for that week they I was going to
bring the papers but I didn't know if it
was a bit too much um they go over um
the the cuts um rent everything and then
they show you like how much you actually
get paid for that week
um so I I go in and you're not supposed
to have candles in your room because
it's a fire
hazard I don't give a [__] I I put money
into this establishment I'm going to
have candles so they found
candles and they were like um you know
that's ground for immediate
termination so I'm sitting there and I'm
like [__] I just got fired for some damn
candles that's what I'm
thinking um come to find out it was just
a warning but as she pulls out the uh
receipt she's like you know what um how
about I don't pay you for this week and
like rips it in front of me so
I'm like in my head I'm like should I
just flip the table right now like go
berserk or just stay calm and Collective
because that week I made a lot of money
and I was really counting on that check
I I was getting like a $8,000 check for
that
week and um I just got up and I I left
the room and I went to the um owner and
I pretty much told him like what the
manager did I'm like that's very
uncalled for like am I getting paid like
what's going on because some ranches um
they can withhold your check for
whatever reason so that's kind of like
legal sex trafficking if you ask me you
know what I'm
saying there's so much Shady business
that goes on in that is
Shady and um he ended up telling the
general manager that I guess I told him
my concerns ever since then she started
moving very funny towards me they would
randomly search my room pretty much
treat me like a criminal why why are you
searching my room cuz you think I'm what
stealing money money that I made for the
company you guys are stealing money from
us why are you guys searching our rooms
that we pay rent for that to me just
doesn't sit right I just feel like these
ranches need to change how they treat
these
women we're not employees we're keeping
the Lights On The Water you guys are
living off of the money that we make off
our bags like what is the ideal way that
this business should be run it should
function if we're going to leg legalize
it or if they're going to legalize it
semi Legalize It men should not be
running this business I'm sorry they
should not it should be women that have
been sex workers that know the ins and
outs um most of these men that run these
houses they take advantage and want to
[__] the girls and yeah it's
no yeah we talked about this last time
you do think it should be
legalized yeah I I I believe so yeah it
should be legalized but do it right you
know what I'm saying um I feel like so I
come from working in spas in in New York
right so how it is out there is it's 250
for a massage and a hand job the girl
keeps her clothes on whatever the client
wants to do in the room she can upsell
and charge whatever she keeps 100% of
those tips now out of the 250 she gives
half to the the uh spa and she gets the
other half
that's how I feel like it should be run
you know have a set price for massages
in Nuru and then whatever the girl wants
to do fetishes BDS she can up so and
have her keep 100% of the tips you know
these ranches they want half of the tips
they want half of the party then we got
to pay rent and we got to pay doctor's
fees it's it's a lot you know and then
taxes too it's out of everything the
girls only getting like a a
10% you know profit it's crazy you guys
get checked by a doctor and all that
stuff regularly
yeah
yeah what are you doing I mean you
mentioned you're you're doing something
now with women that are doing this kind
of work yeah so now I Mentor other
ladies um and I just pretty much tell
them the ins and outs which sites to
post on um what prices which cities to
to
work and how to answer the phone screen
clients so is it for girls that are
looking to get into
it well most of the girls I've been
mentoring are from the ranches so a lot
of them been word of mouth telling their
friends hey you know Susie's been a
great help I've had a lot of girls where
you know they text me back after like
two weeks thank you so much I made 15
grand this week off of I'm like
yes I love it you know help out other
ladies you know I'm not trying to
exploit any anybody I'm not trying to
[__] these women I'm just just one sex
work from another we're just here to you
know help you're
good-hearted girl who's trying to help
yes but and you're also still working as
well I am yeah my clients don't need me
you know so got to be there for
them and you're happy I am just a little
lonely
sometimes it is do you think one day
you'll be able to
separate the connection you've clearly
made between money and
sex or money and
love that's a hard
one I don't know because it's like I
don't want to be with somebody that
doesn't have anything going for
themselves you have a lot of years of
conditioning
yeah oh that that's a hard One MH
yeah that is a hard one I mean I'm a
hopeless romantic I mean I would love to
be in a relationship and have kids
eventually but if it doesn't happen it
doesn't
happen What can I do
so do you think that because you're a
sex
worker that you are
less
desirable I don't I don't think so I
don't either I think there's a sea of
men who find you more attractive because
you're doing
this well I mean you're probably more
experienced yes I'm definitely more
experienced um what I could say I do
love sex I mean I I'm a very sexual
person so I'm a great lover that's
that's what I can say
so that's a hell of a selling point yeah
and I'm a good cook too
so it's a
winwin where would you like to be in 5
years
okay what would I like H have a business
definitely um have my house right now I
have an apartment I just moved to Jersey
and it's super expensive paying like
3,000 a month for that I could just get
a house and pay off mortgage so
definitely want to get a house within
the next
year um and yeah once I get my business
going um
legitimate uh definitely retire from the
industry and and if I don't have anybody
by then um I still want to become a
foster
mom really yeah yeah but once I have
like my my business and then I can just
like give my businesses to the foster
children and then they can run it and
you know yeah you can move to the
counties where prostitution is legalized
in Nevada and you could do it legally be
be a matter yeah that that too but um I
also want to get into the Wii business
um I actually just submitted my
application in Jersey so I'm waiting for
them to get back to me to grow um so I
want to have my foot in different you
know businesses not just only that um
but
yeah probably do like a weed
infused uh I was also thinking like a a
luxury dining experience as well cuz I
love to cook so
yeah you seem like a very good-hearted
woman to be in
this line of work this lifestyle you
have to you have to you can't um I
believe in karma you know and I I've met
a lot of uh women in the industry uh
that Rob their clients you know
just just messed up broken Souls they're
just I don't know why they would be in
the industry in the first place but
um yeah you can't Rob your clients you
got to treat everybody with compassion
and some people are just Hustlers
they're just born I I get that I'm a
hustler too but you know what's right is
right and what's wrong is wrong you
don't Rob your clients you know just
don't do that so there's a lot of girls
that do it in the industry and it it
frustrates me because it kind of sheds a
bad light on us as a whole you know not
every provider does that I sure don't I
don't have to rob my clients you know
they pay my prices so have you had sugar
daddies uh I have one I have one he's I
can't mention his name he's a
biotech uh it's well
known yeah he's he's much older he's
like in his 70s I like older men so but
that seems to
be an ideal relationship for a Girl Like
You
yeah
um but like eventually I want to I want
something serious you know and he's
always like on the go always
like traveling out the country sometimes
it's hard to get a hold of him and
um I have love for him because he's such
a I don't know this is kind of I don't
know if this is weird
but I don't know if I have like Daddy
Issues my father's never been around so
I think just
[Music]
him taking care of me that kind of turns
me on like he's never pressured me to
like have sex with him like when we
first started dating I didn't want to
have sex with him for the first like two
months I was just like just give me
money and and then one day I just
realized I'm like no you got to
reciprocate you know what I'm saying I
can't just keep taking
and and yeah I just we had sex it was
good wasn't bad I can't complain for men
it's very clear men get physically
attracted first and then they become
emotionally
attached for women they need to be
emotionally attached and then they
become physically attracted yes yes mhm
cuz at first I'm like wow he's he's much
older than me like he can
be my
grandfather um but the fact that he's
hanging out yeah without any sex and
he's very respectful never like never
gave me the
the creeps like I know there's some guys
out there that just be like too much
like I've I've done dinner dates and the
guy's like all touchy feely like can't
keep it like relaxed just you know like
he's not like that at all so I think
that's what um turns me on about him and
then of course he you know he takes care
of me you know whenever I need anything
he'll you know so yeah he's trying to
get me pregnant which is crazy I'm like
no I'm not not having your kid I don't
care how much money you are you're
getting older and
eventually you know you're going to die
I don't know how how much longer you
have but I don't want to be stuck
raising a kid by myself and then is he
healthy he looks he looks healthy so you
live to be
95 then it's like he can't run with the
kid it's like you know can't do like
certain
activities you know what I'm
saying
I'm just playing Devil's Advocate
yeah if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
differently
nothing nothing everything in my life is
a lesson learned so I'm grateful for
whatever you know
I everything I've been through with
forer care and just it's made me the
person I am today so forever
grateful
it's interesting so many people I've
interviewed have
had Sometimes some of the most horrible
things happen to them and I asked that
question and they all say I wouldn't
change a
thing I
wouldn't because it makes you who you
are mhm
yeah and um I don't want to get
emotional but
um the older I get I feel like um I have
like a guardian angel
um I used to always
um kind of hate my
mom and be like why uh why me why am I
forced to care why is this happening to
me
um oh thank you but as I got
older I'm like okay now I see the bigger
picture
um God or my guardian angel the higher
up you know was protecting me from my
mom my mom was never mentally stable and
I'm over here sitting and saying why
this and why that but there's kids in
different countries being sex trafficked
killed other people got it worse right
now I mean look at what's happening in
Israel you know
so
I what I could say is that I haven't had
it that bad you know what I'm saying I'm
I'm forever grateful and
I yeah that's all I can say and you're
you're still young yeah MH you have a
lot of decades
yet yeah and also um I've been taking a
lot of shrooms lately so it's been
clearing my mind and just making me sit
and think like I can't hate my mom you
know like my mom been through a lot of
[__] um
and she was young when she had me you
know she was she has three
kids she had her first son when she was
16 and she got pregnant right after and
then she had me when she was 20
so I could only
imagine you know what she went through I
can't hate her I have to forgive for
myself for yourself yeah hating only
hurts yeah only hurts you yeah and it's
like why am I going to dwell in that
time period I'm going to be stuck in
that time period for the rest of my life
I have to move on you know so
yeah it's hard
but one one day at a time you know
you're doing great all right Susy well
was great seeing you again thank you for
it's great seeing you thank you for
having me sure thanks for the
update and maybe we'll do another one
one
day all right thank you very much take
care